outside the town of a dammer in the Nile
River State 15 000 young volunteers have
already enlisted in this training camp
family members come to show support
deny River State will buy the will of
God remain safe and secure your brothers
and all security sectors are Vigilant
they never sleep and will make sure no
single traitor will set for in the state
our camps are super ready to receive and
train more recruits what you see here
are our Reserve brigades ready to join
the battle
after three months of fighting between
the Army and the paramilitary rap
support forces or rsf a nationwide
recruiting campaign is underway
Quran has instructed all regional Army
commanders to start enlisting and
training all able-bodied volunteers
Sudan civilians have also started to
join
we are at an average military Camp
receiving training on how to use
firearms and stand up in defense of our
people and our nation
the recent assassination of the governor
of West Darfur followed by reports of
the killing of thousands of civilians in
Geneva at the hands of tribal factions
and Rapid support forces has sent shock
waves across the country
I call on the International Community to
come to the rescue of our people in
Darfur right now they are under siege
with no hospitals or pharmacies or food
or water six thousand people have died
many of them were killed while trying to
flee to Chad
it's all good news for the Sudanese Army
but with some major tribes in the
country taking part there is concerned
that the conflict may become ethnic in
nature Sudan has been through such
experience twice before no one here
wants to repeat Muhammad Al Jazeera Port
Sudan